Philadelphia is a strange city. That's a strange city. Ah, their, um,
their like famous snack or meal, right.
It's a Philly cheese steak, right? That's not cheese. That's liquid,
powdered sugar. Yeah. With the yellow food coloring. Yeah.
That's not steak. Now. That is, I don't know what that is. Steak.
Those are from me and Chad. Yeah.
It's basically fake steak and fake cheese on a hero bread. Yeah.
Okay. And then as their statue, they have Rocky. That's a fake boxer.
Yeah. And then they got a mayor that says the word Negro this way,
cue it up. Mike Marsh.
I found out as the police chief, that the black in any area in,
particularly in Philadelphia, wants to know more than I want.
He wants to be secure in his home.
He wants to be able to walk the streets and safety.
He wants to be able to have his children educated without them being shot or
stabbed in school.
And I thought that the black community was against me.
I would have not run from there. Of course. Uh, uh,
about 600,000 Negroes live on [inaudible].
[Inaudible] right there. Negroes.
I've never heard Negro pronounced that way.
I've never heard Negro with an N because that was the mayor of Philadelphia.
He pronounced it Negroes. He was literally,
he stopped himself mid word because he was a millisecond away from
letting one fly. Yeah. Cause I mean, Philadelphia is a wild town.
I mean, because he's being interviewed on public television,
he almost said the N word. Yeah. I mean, he kinda S it was, you know, that,
you know, that meme where that baby runs into the room and then goes woo.
And runs back. He kind of started the word and went, Ooh, get it that way.
Holy. ISIS. Have you ever heard it pronounced nig? Rose?
Can we play it one more time? Let's just hear it one more time.
There was no camera tricks. That, that was him. That was 600,000.
Negroes living.
I mean, Frankie. Yeah.
What do you think his PR team did when they,
he said he thinks one of them passed out.
He obviously did not have a PR team for care or his PR rep you
know, whose PR rep was cool.
His PR rep was a guy named Vinny from the neighborhood. He said, listen,
when you make what you talk about the blacks, make sure,
make sure you say the word and you say it this way. Yeah. His,
his PR guy was a guy named Paulie, publicity
bullied for busy from South Philly,
Pauline published in a year from South Philly.
And now you just go up there and you know, just don't say the N word,
but you could come close Elisha. He goes,
listen, just don't say it full. But you know, let the people know who you,
where are you from? His wife is going
to make you a couple of state comes when you came here. You came here
because let's be crystal clear about something
their 30 year ma Mrs. Rizzo,
unfortunately disciplined the few times she had a few black eyes for the
pictures. There was just a time or two.
There was just a time or two where Mr. And Mrs. Rachel showed up to an event.
And unfortunately Mrs. Michelle had to bring her friend Lucile to do her makeup
pitch just because she had a black attitude. Cause she was disciplined.
It's just what it is.
That's what happens if you put a little too much garlic in the sauce for Frank
risk.